fasting is banned mosques are destroyed
and saying assalamu alaikom forget about
it of course I'm talking about the
weaker Muslims of Chinese occupied East
Turkestan what we know now today as the
Xinjiang Uighur autonomous region
located in the northwest of China a
country which borders with India
Pakistan Tajikistan Afghanistan
Kyrgyzstan Kazakhstan Russia to the
north and Mongolia Ramadan has arrived
and at a time where we may be upset
because of the coronavirus that we won't
be able to go to the mosque and pray
taraweeh together let's put things into
perspective and see what the weaker
Muslims go through every Ramadan they
are not able to fast they are not able
to own Koran they cannot pray they
cannot give their children Muslim names
they are forced to drink alcohol and eat
pork especially during the month of
Ramadan shopkeepers are forced to sell
alcohol and pork wiggers are not allowed
to go to Hajj so any form of Islam is
totally totally banned even saying
Islamic phrases like assalamu alaykum
subhanAllah al hamdulillah
Allahu Akbar forget about it this will
land you in a concentration camp you may
have seen in the media recently the vast
majority of concentration camps
arbitrarily detaining Wigga Muslims
simply for having a beard or wearing
hijab or practicing Islam in anyway
these camps are the same if not worse
then what happened to the Jews over 75
years ago yes this is a Muslim holocaust
happening in 2020 where Muslims go
through various forms of torture like
sterilization
gang rape of both men and women children
are also taken away and adopted off to
Han Chinese families people go through
tortures like sitting in Tiger chairs
for hours on end interrogated for days
sleep deprivation atrocities that are
unheard of so yes while we may be going
through a difficult time with covert 19
this Ramadan think about your Muslim
brothers and sisters the weakest while
we are locked in our comfy homes still
allowed to practice in our homes living
in the free world the Whig and Muslims
themselves can't even practice Islam in
their own home because 1.1 million
Chinese officials are forced to live
with
Regas and monitor each and every move
imagine someone forced you to live with
a government official and they monitored
each and every move that you made the
language that you spoke whether you
practice Islam or not and one wrong move
can land you in to a concentration camp
where you will not know whether you'll
come out alive or dead and even the ones
that do end up dying in these camps we
don't get the body back you will not be
able to give a jenessa because they
cremate the bodies to hide the evidence
of torture another issue
helau organ harvesting you may have
heard of this term before hello organ
harvesting is where organs of Wigga
muslims are taken and sold off to the
highest bidders in the Middle East you
can do your own research about all the
things that I've talked about because it
has been well documented by Western
media and well-known human rights
organizations all around the world well
what can you do as a regular Muslim or a
regular human being join us in the fight
against China we all had access to
social media apps like Facebook
Instagram Twitter all these sort of
social media apps that we take for
granted are absolutely banned follow us
on our page talk to East Turkestan
follow our twitter ad Arslan underscore
he Dyer and share the work that we do do
your bit you know sometimes we take
things like social media for granted you
have to ask yourself why does the
Chinese communist regime ban all those
apps that I just mentioned because they
want to hide the truth they want to save
face well we need to show the world just
how murderous this Chinese regime
actually is